[Applaudissements]
il y a quelques semaines j'ai fait mon
centième anniversaire et super calme
d'abord je suis passé d'un corps de 50
ans a encore de 40 ans sipa première
fois j'ai fait à son effigie
régénérative mais le cadeau de plus
excitant pour moi pour un geek comme moi
ça a été les choix de mon prochain un
plan cérébral
d'ailleurs à la fin de ce tome
vous serez le cas de crise évidemment
j'ai expliqué à mes arrière arrière
arrière arrière petits-enfants
pourquoi d'excitation les enfants
augmente et humain ça fait parti de
l'accélération du global habitait ce
changement vous voyez aujourd'hui c'est
la vitesse de chargement la plus lente
que vous verrez pour le résoudre
oui augmenté l'humain fait partie de
l'accélération de la vitesse
vous voyez aujourd'hui c'est la vitesse
de changement la plus lente
vous verrez pour la réserve alors mon
excitation a démarré en 2007 en 2016
il ya quelques startups qui sont venus
extrêmement visible dans le maine dans
le domaine de l'alimentation du cerveau
qu'on appelle aussi le hacking du syngof
une d'entre elles car elles fondées par
ryan johnson visa 1 canal j pour gérer
les déficiences dégâts créés par un avc
ou les dégénérescences en live une honte
nora lutte a été fondée par pilote
weedon musk d'être l'époque avait créé
cela sp6 et bien en 2016 plaide près de
700 millions de dollars investis dans
l'hérault tête un certain donald en 2017
c'est d'un milliard de dollars investis
je me souviens en 2018 sommet finitude
plus de vingt start-up déclaraient
travailler sur l'augmentation du cerveau
d'une manière ou d'une autre je ne parle
pas des grosses entreprises qui avance
masqué maintenant à l'honneur il était
parti de la simple observation suivante
l'interface entre le cerveau ordinateur
est extrêmement inefficace du ton irrité
à l'époque par la vitesse de frappe a
réclamé des kayaks et par la vision sur
des écrans finalement d'ailleurs
relativement au rhénus la mission donnée
à nora lynch était de créer une
interface qui booste cette communication
entre le cerveau ordinateur il a fallu
attendre 2000 gratuite pour que deux
rallyes sur son premier produit il est
extrêmement cher il nécessite une
délicate intervention de près de 12
heures au niveau du serveur le premier
lot a été réservé à augmenter des
experts en intelligence artificielle en
robotique en biologie en neurosciences
et grâce à cette augmentation ces
experts ont un levier incroyable pour
recréer des implants qui soit rapide et
peu chères à déployer en arrivant de 32
ils sont près de réussir
et c'est là le moment que choisit de la
meuse pour partir sur mars
c'était son fantasme que l'homme
devienne une espèce unique planétaire
donc il est parti mais il sait très bien
qu'ils restent pas revenir puisqu'il
fait pour compléter son travail durant
nos ralink un géant internet de l'époque
amazon quand le premier sort ne prend
que deux à être déployée grâce aux
technologies de nos euros
12h02 accélération moi j'avais je
m'étais inscrite pour être un des
premiers clients et gély la première
augmentation de 5 ce qui a augmenté mes
capacités mais absolument extraordinaire
en 2040 les écrans commencent à
disparaître des implants deviennent
tellement puissant que les écrans de
rimbach la réalité augmentée quel point
avez connu dans les années 2020 2030
avec des dispositifs extérieur d'espèces
de lunettes genre de choses ça n'existe
pas maintenant notre cerveau voit
combinaison de notre vision et des
images grippale
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
fabricants de smartphones et
d'ordinateurs ont été aussi nerveux et
ils sont rentrés dans ce marché est
autant des pénalités ça change tout pour
eux c'est plus d'ego c'est ce qu'on
appelle un changement de paradigme
majeur dans l'expérience utilisateur
évidemment je me suis garé et j'ai pris
cette nouvelle version
puis des contres de beau papa style
il a
on arrive à une autre situation on en
les implants commence à travailler sur
les hormones et les neurotransmetteurs
notre ans auteur sida mais de gérer les
émissions temps partir de là les impôts
peuvent faire déplaire vidéo en 3d le
film 3d de ce qu'on ressent clichés ou
doha - le goût et peut rejouer une piste
et monsieur il interprète la peste
émotionnelle pour créer des variations
d'une au transmetteur de récré les
émissions dans la musique sacrée
évidemment de commissions communication
extrêmement riche du malin mais pas que
il faut vous rappeler que ça rappelons
aussi tester et implémenter sur les
animaux plus précis sur les mammifères
pour la desserte intérieure
donc on oublie la communication avec le
poisson rouge en mai mais si les chiens
n'a plus aucun secret pour moi ils ont
leurs implants pour dire que ça fait
très longtemps que je suis plus trouvé
de roquettes n'a pas de la communauté
chez avec des animaux est bien plus
important que ça posez vous cette
question est-ce que vous soyez capable
de manger la viande d'un animal vivant
alors que vous avez ressenti les
émulsions la détresse de l'animal
lorsqu'il arrive à la victoire
et bien que ça une grande partie de la
population est devenue végétarienne de
partie de la population à manger de la
protéine animale qui provient de viande
élevée en laboratoire donc non plus d'un
animal y vante d'ailleurs des
visionnaires comme charles manson et
bill gates en 2016 2017 avait investi
dans une entreprise c'est memphis beat
qui crée des viandes de laboratoire
autre avantage la quantité de viande
égale produits cc - portion des terres
nécessaires et seulement 10 % de l'eau
nécessaire pour produire la même
chronique
c'est la grande distribution
et fabricants se sont mis à s'attaquer à
un énorme problème
non que tout le monde a la mémoire le
souvenir notre mémoire est parfaite on
nous dit déchets et on les transforme
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu un petit
combat avec un de vos proches sur le
souvenir d'un événement comme si vous
avez pas brigue lui exactement d'un
événement ceux qui sont contre elle eh
bien ça m'est arrivé j'ai été bien
traité
on s'était longtemps et beaucoup les
autonomies il était une propriété
personnelle
c'est un élément qu'on peut pas oublier
j'étais avec mon épouse dix minutes
après l'événement déclarations à la
police
j'ai déclaré que mon agresseur avait un
couteau
ma femme a déclaré qu'il ya des normes à
dix minutes près donc oui de souvenirs
sont extrêmement parfois potable et ses
petites histoires
ce projet d'accord avec ma femme c'est
ma maman qui est imparfaite
ce groupe comprend donc bien en 2056 les
implants sauvegarde en temps réel au
sexe et aux émotions on peut rejouer à
redouter les premiers mois rappelez-vous
d'impact sur la justice les
investigations ont été accélérés par un
facteur de 1000 au moins les victimes
les suspects et les témoins n'ont plus à
raconter leur histoire ils ont juste à
fournir leur enregistrement personnel de
l'événement accélération on arrive à
maintenir aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ça fait quelques mois
maintenant que tous les fabricants
d'implants fournisseurs d un plan arabe
sera observée ce que c'est on absorbe
les différentes versions
depuis les quelques dernières dizaines
d'années et quelques clics
si vous vous sentez fasciné en fait il
est fait signer aussi mais en fait on
passe au bon dieu
une session j'ai en temps réel tous les
trucs qui me permet de négocier le
meilleur pour moi quelle que soit c'est
comme ça que je me suis retrouvé le
ciseau il engage tous les langages
je les comprends je n'ai pas là pour
dire aux machines agi d'un master pour
démarrer cette présentation que j'avais
vu du débat dire bonjour quand je les
marathons par an la surenchère et à la
nouvelle identification personnes dès
l'instant je rencontre quelqu'un que
j'ai déjà rencontré non seulement
reconnaître instantanément mais j'ai
aussi l'ensemble des éléments de ma
relation avec lui qui me sont fournis
résumé les détails avec là où j'ai
rencontré 43 fois dans un environnement
business on a tout essayé mais c'est mon
contrat et je lui aussi rencontré trois
fois dans des lieux que la décence ce
matin lire ici 4
humour est répartie ça c'est pour les
gens qui savent pas raconter des blagues
comme en espagne en public il est
absolument pas peur de parler en public
devant 200 personnes avec en plus le lot
d'histoires et d'histoire qui impacte
n'a jamais été aussi rapide et facile
d'apprendre une nouvelle compétence
accélérations mais je vous parlais de
l'application phare contrôle sur tous
les amants absolument tous les bons
coups
brain books a pris avantage de cette
capacité de partager l'événement et la
glèbe moi il le succès doit donc c'est
un celi fonction in real life en
fonction dans la vie réelle on rencontre
quelqu'un dans la vie réelle qui a des
valeurs compatibles et que vous touchez
cette personne
ils ont pensé à la main eh bien vous
échanger instantanément des valeurs des
pensées et des émotions des souvenirs
ce qui a fait le succès est absolument
incroyable de boîtes book c'est le
détournement de cette fonction de 2
milliards d'utilisateurs en seulement 30
jours
c'est la plus forte croissance on n'est
jamais vu pour une application alors
pour exprimer cette recette de
croissance organique et comment ça
pousse a été détourné je vais prendre
trois si la turn black book ici je vais
prendre la personne et des deux
personnes qui sont là sont les bienvenus
apprenant qu'ils viennent nous expliquer
bref books permet est partagée aussi ses
pensées les plus intimes ses fantasmes
et en fonction de la compatibilité entre
ce que je pense
est-ce que de penser à des réactions
très violentes
s
alors c'est très intéressant on a des
valeurs communes jeu
j'adopte ou même certaines ton état
d'esprit je pense qu'on veut faire notre
business en sont donc en difficulté
après le redoute qu'elle subit je
commençais ça c'était une accélération
business le vide total
on partagerait du tour bon ok c'est
gentil merci je peux prétendre ou est ce
qui te trompes d'accélération à un
papable corps au moment où ça c'est bon
on arrête je suis obligé d'arrêter parce
que si j'avais par été on va se parler d
un angle à zoom simultanée ici sur cette
terre je vis est libre expression
scénique tour renversé santé alors oui
pour rappel donc une augmentation du mal
ça fait parti de cette expérience au
volant et la vitesse de changement lui
c'est vraiment la vitesse des
changements des plantes que vous verrez
pour le résultat une accélération
je vous ai promis je vous dirai quel
aplomb qui avait choisi le moment de
dire c'est maintenant fait mettant une
autre démonstration vous faire
démonstration d'appétence négociations
moi je voyais tout à l'heure vos
compétences vous vous touchez pas entre
vous parce qu'avec lui accorde pas
debout pendant cinq ans ce qui pourrait
se passer et nous voilà donc en pause
j'ai choisi c'est en fait je vais
partager sur vannes oc
donc si vous voulez savoir si des mois
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]